alright Brett is with us Brett is in
North Carolina
hi Brett how are you hey Dave thank you
so much for taking my call it's an honor
to speak with you you too so I came home
back in August and unfortunately
everything well my wife had left my
house and left a letter she wanted a
separation I've been going through that
and so we had about 10,000 thought we
were debt-free I've been following you
for a long time so we didn't have any
debt we had about $10,000 and she took
after that so I was less than about 5
and then I had to get a lawyer you know
that's the 2,000 retainer and then my
car worked down of course had to spend a
thousand to get it fixed and all the
stuff I'm basically down to a couple
thousand dollars and I'm just making
enough to get by every month right now
because I still let her be on my I can't
be divorced
until next August because you have to
wait a year in North Carolina so I'm not
out of money yet you know but I'm
getting really low and I was just
wondering if I should think about I mean
I don't see a way around getting alone
to pay my lawyer fee right because it's
ended up being around a thousand a month
from my lawyer and I was trying to save
at least three to five hundred if I
could um but you know I was left with
the house and mortgage and everything so
I'm paying for all of that right now I
was just going over there I'm 29 okay
how long were you married two years and
two months my goodness I'm sorry okay
I don't know North Carolina law this is
the first time I've ever heard of a
state taking a year to get a divorce
unless the parties involved were both
had the serial so and I don't know why
you would pay your lawyer $1,000 a month
while we sit and wait on this clock to
take a $12,000 divorce for a two-year
marriage for a 20
you're old that's not well it's just
been paying for making the separation
agreement and getting all of that
settled you know yeah but I mean again
you said a thousand dollars a month what
do you make I make 80 thousand a year
and she looked she wasn't working so why
are you broke on you make $80,000 get
here where's all the money going you
told me you didn't have any debt I don't
so like I said it's it seems like it's
like I spent $1,600 there's a lawyer
last year maybe I just have to use what
you said I thought you said you paid him
$2,000 retainer out of your savings I
did so how much money have you given
this guy total so it was 2000 for the
retainer and then I've spent last Mont I
spent 1600 on top of the retainer you
know next year yeah and in the months
before that was about seven or eight
hundred okay okay I think you need to
have a discussion with your lawyer about
when these legal fees are gonna end
because this is a very expensive divorce
attorney considering there's nothing
here to contest and there's no real
argument going on okay do you have
children
no sir okay are you paying her money no
sir
good okay so you have $80,000 coming in
and what is your so your monthly
take-home pay is what seven thousand six
thousand bucks yes what's your house
payment ten thousand okay that leaves
five thousand dollars to get by on I'm
sorry I don't know why you can't get by
on this um I think you need a budget I
think your heart is broke another brain
isn't working I've got my every dollar
boat budget I apologize it starts me to
pull it up okay all right no you don't
have any debt payments but a thousand
dollar house payment and you have six or
seven thousand dollars a month coming
home
yes sir yeah I think probably what I
mean you just got them wind knocked out
of you because you got you got
gut-punched here brother you're hurting
and that that causes your brain to be in
a fog a little bit that's all normal but
I'm just pointing out that
mathematically you should have plenty of
room in this budget yeah I know a big
part of my paycheck goes to my health
insurance because she had some health
problems and so like 700 I get paid
every two weeks and 350 I each paycheck
goes to you I think you need to figure
out where the six or seven thousand
dollars is going sir I haven't found
anything in this discussion that tells
me where it's going in it's very
difficult time for you I'm sorry you're
hurting but normal human beings when
we're hurting our math brain doesn't
work as good so dial in on that and I
think you're okay no you don't need a
loan you need to tighten up and live on
what you've got coming in